الثامن عشر من فبراير عام الفين
وواحد في بالقرب من منزله في
الفيدرالي الامريكي استطاع الروس
تجنيد هانسون كجاسوس لهم واستمر
وسبعين. بعد ثلاث سنوات من
انضمامه الى مكتب التحقيقات
حتى عام واحد وتسعين عندما قطع
الاتصالات خلال انهيار الاتحاد
فيينا فيرجينيا بعد تركه لحزمة
من الملفات السرية في موقع تسليم
السوفيتي خوفا من ان يكشف عاد
الاتصالات في العام التالي
وسائل تعقبهم والامساك بهم.
وبينما كانت مهمته الكشف عن
جون كيريدي شخصيا من تثبيت سوفيت
لنظام الصواريخ العابرة للقارات
امكانية الافراج المشروط. فرنسا
تطرد بعض الدبلوماسيين الروس من
جاسوس وايهم غير ذلك. والحقيقة
ان موسكو تستطيع تجنيد الجواسيس
واستمر اعتقاله. باع هانسون الاف
الوثائق السرية للاستخبارات
الجاسوس الالماني كلاوسفوكس عالم
بالطبيعة النووية وواحدا من ضمن
متفق عليه مع الروس وحكم عليه
بالسجن المؤبد خمس عشرة مرة دون
للمخابرات الامريكية والبريطانية
ثم اختفى لذلك تأكد الاعتقاد
الاتحاد السوفيتي صواريخ في
كوبا. فقد حذر الرئيس الامريكي
المشروع كاملا لصالح الاستخبارات
السوفيتية وبالرغم من ذلك لم يكن
الذي كانت تشترك فيه بريطانيا
وامريكا وقد قام بافشاء اسرار
الروسية التي الاستراتيجيات
الامريكية في حالة الحرب النووية
والتطورات في تقنيات الاسلحة
العسكرية وجوانب من برنامج
جعله رمزا للجاسوسية. روبرت
هانسون في عام وتسعمائة وتسعة
جاسوسا متمرسا لكنه قضى قرابة ست
سنوات في نقل المعلومات وهذا
مكافحة التجسس الامريكي. ساعد
هانسون الجواسيس الروس في تجنب
الجواسيس الاجانب في امريكا صار
يؤدي عمله بطريقة عكسية. فيكشف
حتى من كوادر اعدائها. كما جرت
عادة الجاسوسية الروسية. فهل
عن الجواسيس الامريكان وينقذ
جواسيس روسيا القبض على هانسن في
اراضيها. وتفعل بريطانيا الشيء
ذاته وهو ما تفعله الغرب في حالة
مما يعتقد الامريكان ما منع قيام
حرب نووية بين الولايات المتحدة
يحمل الاسم الرمزي هيرو. وكان
عقيدا في الاستخبارات العسكرية
هستيرية اليوم هم لا يعلمون اي
من الروس المتواجدين في اراضيهم
قدم خدمات عظيمة للاستخبارات
البريطانية. لكن في الوقت نفسه
نظير خدماته وتطلب الامر ثماني
سنوات للتأكد من خيانته فعليا
الحرب الباردة. وقد نجح في تحضير
بريطانيا وامريكا حول نصب
بروفومير. كيم فيلدي خدع
المخابرات البريطانية بشدة. حيث
خلال تحقيقات طويلة لكن كيم
فيلبي كان قد هرب لموسكو ليعيش
خلال معرفتها بالملحق العسكري
السوفيتي بيرجين ايفانوف الذي
جذورها. وبسبب تداعيات القضية
فقد تضررت ثقة رئيس الوزراء
السوفيتية. وهو صاحب الفضل في
عدم قيام حرب حقيقية بدلا من
بنكوفسكي من مواليد الف وتسعمائة
وتسعة عشر جاسوس المخادع والذي
بروفومو وزير الدولة للحرب
منصبا. وقضية بروفومو في عام
العلماء الذين يعملون في مشروع
مانهاتن لصنع القنبلة الذرية
في كوبا. واقنعهم ان القدرة
العسكرية السوفيتي هي اكبر كثيرا
والاتحاد السوفيتي. كانت تلك
المعلومات هي الوحيدة التي قدمها
كان ينقل الرسائل الى سوفيت خلال
الحرب العالمية الثانية اثناء
بريطانيا حتى ان الحكومة منحته
وسام الامبراطورية البريطانية
بانه كان مزروعا من قبل السوفيت
لمنع الحرب. الجاسوس النووي. كان
بل انها قامت بنقل اسرار حربية
بريطانية للمخابرات الروسية من
حينها ماك ميلان تقدم استقالته
من رئاسة الوزراء. ليس هذا فحسب
حياة الابطال هناك. الشبح
الروسي. اوليج فلاديميروفيتش
مهامه بين استراليا واسبانيا
وتركيا وامريكا لبنان. وقد خدع
طلب منها العمل كجاسوسة عندما
علم بعلاقتها مع الوزير
السرية بواسطة جاي برجس وكان
عميلا سوفيتيا مزدوجا. وكان قد
واحد وستين هي فضيحة سياسية
لبريطانيا وتتضمن علاقة جنسية
قصيرة ترنحت بسببها وزارة
بريطانيا وقتها واهتزت من
كان شخصية محورية في الاحداث وقد
تم تجنيده لخدمة المخابرات
والتي ادى جمالها الرائع في سن
المراهقة الى ان يفقد جون
هدت عرش بريطانيا. كريستين كيل
فاتنة الجواسيس الاكثر جمالا
الوصول اليها طيلة ذلك الوقت.
انها ميليتانو. الجاسوسة التي
وفي احد الملفات الموجودة في هذا
الكنز كان اسم اولا مكتوبا بوضوح
ليشيال الجميع عن العميلة التي
فشلت المخابرات البريطانية في
تطور جذري في خطة العلماء الروس
لانتاج القنبلة للاتحاد
التقني للمشروع النووي للاتحاد
السوفيتي. والذي ساهم في صناعة
وتسعين وقد سلم الاستخبارات
البريطانية كنزا ضخما من الوثائق
السوفيتي. المشاكل التقنية التي
تغلبت عليها كانت العائق الرئيس
قدمت ميليتان نوود الملقبة
بالعميلة السرية هولا كل الدعم
هولا طي الكتمان طيلة اربعة عقود
حتى جاءت الهائل الذي قام به
صناعة اول قنبلة ذرية له قبل خمس
سنوات من جدولها المتوقع. ظلت
اصدقائها. وتسببت هذه المساعدات
في نجاح الاتحاد السوفيتي في
امام المشروع النووي السوفيتي
وذلك بحسب ما تضمنه كتاب لاحد
انه تمكن من الهروب من المشنقة
في ذلك الوقت. العميلة هولا.
موسكو. وبعد اعدامه لقب باسم
الاستاذ رغم ان الكثيرين اعتقدوا
المسؤول السابق عن الارشيف
للمخابرات الروسية عام اثنين
جيمس بوند الحقيقية وذلك لانه
غير مسار الحرب العالمية بعمله
نضيعه امام شاشات التلفاز. جيمس
بوند روسيا. ريتشارد سيرج. واحد
المعلومات اهمها هي التي قدمها
عن نية النازحين الى احتلال
مظاهرة حاشدة وليسوا جواسيس
متخفين. على خسارة وقتنا الذي
كجاسوس فقد كان يتقن الكثير من
اللغات كما انه قدم الكثير من
من اشهر وانجح الجواسيس في
التاريخ. والكثير يشبهه بشخصية
وتسعين. بينما لم يتم القبض على
هذا العدد الضخم من الجواسيس حتى
قدم لموسكو معلومات خطيرة عن
العملاء المزدوجين داخل روسيا
مما ادى الى اعتقال موسكو مائة
من الجواسيس المتعاملين مع
بحبكاتهم التكتيكية لتأتي روسيا
وتقبض عليهم بالجملة وكأنهم في
واشنطن بعد اقتضاح امرهم. وهو ما
اعترف به مدير سي اي عام خمسة
في عهد النازي هتلر. يا الهي ما
الذي حدث عندها? هل هؤلاء جواسيس
تطوع للتجسس لصالح الاتحاد
السوفيتي ومن بعده روسيا. حيث
والاستخبارات الامريكية مثل
الضابط السابق في سي اي ايه الذي
اكبر مجزرة في تاريخ الاستخبارات
العالمية. ويتذكر المسؤولون
امريكا الذين نشاهد افلامهم
ومسلسلاتهم في هوليود? فنعجب
الامريكيون تمكن روسيا تجنيد
ضباط ومسؤولين في اجهزة الامن
مهماتهم بكل دقة واصبحوا مصدر
رعب لكل استخبارات العالم.
المنظمة التي ورثت جهاز
الاستخبارات السوفيتية. مجزرة
جاسوسا او تعمل في مجال
الاستخبارات الدولية. انها
الاحزمة كي ننطلق بهذه الرحلة
المشوقة من جواسيس روسيا حول
الاهم من ذلك هو نجاح المهمة
التي اتوا من اجلها. وينفذون
العالم. هذا المصطلح الذي قد لا
تعرفه انت او غيرك الا ان كنت
لها يغيرون اشكالهم ولغتهم بل
ويخضعون لعمليات تجميلية لتغيير
الجواسيس. هي العملية التي هزت
اركان استخبارات العالم وصنعت
فهم يشكلون جيش موسكو القوي في
مواجهة اعدائهم. هم لا يدخلون
بعد نجاحهم في مهماتهم او عندما
يكتشفهم الاعداء. لكن وفي كل حال
موسكو في الخفاء. لا يهم حيوا ام
ماتوا. او يتم القبض عليهم.
الاشباح الروسية لا بل جنود
الظلام الذين لا نسمع عنهم الا
المعارك ولا يظهرون في المواجهات
يتكيفون مع المهمة التي يبعثون
لون بشرتهم. هم الايادي الخفية
لروسيا وهم الظل الذي تتحكم به
يدرك الغرب ذلك?